I've always wanted to know why they say if you've never been pregnant or breastfed,
that you have a higher risk for cancer, both through in my case.
Why is that?
Because if you've been pregnant and especially if you breastfed, you've used the lactation
cells for the purposes that they're created.
And by breastfeeding, it's done studies, women who breastfeed longer have a lower risk.
So if you stop breastfeeding at three months and weed your baby at three months versus breastfeeding
for two years and the baby naturally weeds off when that baby doesn't want to breastfeed
anymore, those women have a lower risk of breast cancer and it has to do with the use of the
breast tissue.
So when you use the breast tissue and it's functioning the way it's supposed to function
and it created milk that you do have a lower risk of breast cancer.